do you feel like you're kind of giving
back to other comics and giving them an
opportunity to get out there and huge
definitely yeah it's a big part of
everything you know coming up at the
store and being a worshipper of Mitsy
Shore by the way like I would like try
to find her in books and stuff it all
really started for me I was always a
letterman guy I was obviously a Stern
guy like I said everything that you Jim
Carrey like when the more that I grew up
the more I realized that everything that
I loved truly loved as a child were
these guys that were in one building at
one time or different times and I'm like
wait what and then when I realized this
one's big when I realized that you
didn't have to like pay that college you
needed tens of thousands of dollars for
in comedy you just do it for free
there's a thing called an open mic where
it doesn't cost anything and you can get
better at something that seems fun as
hell like it was Nob brainer for me and
um well you know that's my philosophy I
don't believe in college yeah I believe
in unless you have a passion for
something you know if you want to be an
engineer or you want to be like your
siblings and figure out your [__] up
mother right then you got to go to
school for that but if you have a
passion or art or whatever business or
being entrepreneurial or just starting
something or figuring it out or doing
comedy or being a p why do you go to
school there are now and people take
advantage I believe
maybe there's some good places but
people go to school for standup comedy
which I also don't I don't believe in
that at all me either I like this we're
on the same page so when I found out and
another thing that happened really
between eighth grade and freshman year
is when man on the moon came out and uh
I was going to I was excited to see that
because at the time Jim car's goofiness
and silliness still had my interest big
time and so I went and saw it and it was
this more serious movie and at the
beginning of that Andy cof he's playing
Andy Kaufman and he's at the Improv and
the guy goes I don't think I can afford
to pay you anymore Andy and it was right
then where I realized like wait a second
you can get paid to be in a room with a
microphone and entertain people like
what I remember it hitting me like a ton
of bricks like wait that no way that
that's possible that seems way too good
to be true because again Youngstown
workingclass Town crime everywhere this
and that either you're going to work in
a steel mill or you're going to be a
welder or you're going you got to go to
college and be a doctor which was never
you know I hated school so in that scene
in man on the moon um I'm like what the
[__] and it ends with Andy or uh Tony
Clifton performing at The Comedy Store
main room and I see saw those red Neons
and the red stage which I had seen
glimpses of and things before on HBO or
here or there on the old uh what was
that you guys used to do the comic
relief or whatever yeah and I would see
glimpses of this mysterious cool looking
black and red building so then by the
time time that um by the time that I got
to the store I mean I was just
mesmerized and I believe that the more
you put the building and Mitsy shore on
a pedestal the more you get out of it
you know well I think that that's that's
what manifestation is the fact that you
you know it's like meditating if you're
going to focus on a number you have a
mantra I think the fact that you are so
focused on The Comedy Store and Mitsy
and what that meant and what it is
you're kind of uh you're manifesting
that for yourself because you are
creating being part of creating what is
happening here in Austin in in
podcasting in the mothership in being
able to launch I I just think that
that's your that's your Mantra because
the truth of the matter is people say to
me like if you had to make it today you
know you had to go to The Comedy Store
that was the only place to be seen if
you were a a Kid in Young stand like you
were I mean and and and you did that
that was the only one place the truth of
the matter is that you can you can we
all have technology at our hands you
know I could sit in a hotel room right
now in Austin and broadcast this and
make a moment I couldn't do that in 1978
I I couldn't do it in 1985 right so
there isn't one place but the idea is
and what you're kind of insinuating it's
it's about Focus yeah find that whatever
it is that you want to focus and go
toward that light if that light if that
image is a building and a person and
people then you got to do it you are
probably one of the most focused like
one of the things you said to me last
night was I've been doing this for 10
and a half years you've never missed one
Monday right there hasn't been if you
can download a new episode to kill to
Tony every Monday wherever you get your
podcast but to to be doing something for
10 and a half years and not missing once
right how many days of school did you
miss oh my goodness as many as I was
allowed and then a couple more and work
and and and just the average person
listening misses nobody but when you
find something that means something to
you regardless of how and this is for I
would imagine for the first year and a
half for the first five years it wasn't
as
um I I think it was equally satisfying
for you but it wasn't a huge success yet
right yet it was a success for me
success is finding your path and staying
on your path you know your story that
you're telling is kind of like a Tony
Robin story it
is